The members of BTS are going to serve in the
military. This is going to cost South Korea
billions of dollars. Billions with a “B.” South
Korea has a law that says that all able-bodied
men must serve in the military. But rich, famous
people have always avoided this through a couple
of loopholes. They’ve renounced their citizenship,
they’ve made up health reasons. Oh, and they also
had this entertainment soldier program where
you could get out of serving in the military
by just making propaganda for the military. That
program doesn't exist anymore, by the way. Back
to BTS. They've said that all seven members are
going to serve their two years in the military.
So we won't have like BTS K-Pop for a few years?
It's not a big deal, right? No, it's a huge deal.
This band brings in around $3.6 billion a year to
South Korea's economy. That's the equivalent of
like 26 mid-sized companies combined. This
one band has led to billions of dollars in
the sales of cosmetics, clothes, food, oh, and
tourism. 7% of tourists who go to South Korea
say that they go because of BTS. The question
is, why didn't South Korea's government step
in and help BTS get some exemption for serving
in the army? And should they have done that?